[Applaudissements]
la régie et c'est parce qu'il veut c'est
quoi ça il revient si tu as des couilles
et on me dit viens viens si t'es un
homme
enfin il m'a même dit au pire que ça je
vous le dis on va voir qui c'est parce
que je commence à en avoir assez
c'est qui ça c'est qui c'est qui c'est
qui est en fait c'est pas moi la
surprise quoique aller j'ai une surprise
pour toi qu il ya une énorme star cahoon
et rendra un avant la visite non mais
moi je suis juste l'assistante cette
personne il faut que tu viennes avec moi
non tu connais l'endroit où tu as les
gens dedans cacher ouais ouais moi ça
s'appelle déjà
les gens ils en cash et ussel à la boîte
et a toujours une star faut deviner qe2
à la cabine à bluff est bas dans la
cabine à bluff tu vas devoir
ouais devinez enfin tu va voir qui est
dedans je pense à te faire plaisir et
ses doigts par ses adversaires comme on
avait fait un gros dos attend il ya un
énorme dossat non non c'est plus tard
mais missions plus en belgique après la
contre attaque est bien d'accord on fait
la surprise
[Applaudissements]